[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه اللقطات من العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو وفيها جدل يتصاعد على وقع
ازمه فارغنر خصوصا بعد اول تعليق للرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين بشان ما حدث
وهذه الصور من مكه المكرمه حيث يواصل حجاج
بيت الله الحرام اداء مناسك الحج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد في هذه الليله
دون اي اشاره الى اسم بريجوجن بوتين يقول
ان منظمي عمليه فاجنر خان الوطن ويصف
توهلهم في اراضي روسيا بانقلاب مسلح
وابتزاز وبعد الاشاده بالمقاتلين الرئيس
الروسي يخيرهم بين توقيع عقود مع وزاره
الدفاع او الرحيل الى بيلاروسيا بريغوجين
يكشف عرضا بيلاروسيا بوضع ترتيبات لمواصله
نشاط قواته ويتكتم على التفاصيل واشنطن
تقول انها تجهل مصير المجموعه وتؤكد ابلاغ
موسكو انها تعتبر التمرد شانا داخليا
وعلى وقع تحذيرات من انعكاس ازمه فاغنر
على الجبهات في اوكرانيا ظهور نادر لشويغو
في مقر قياده القوات الروسيه المشاركه في
الحرب القوات الاوكرانيه تعلن تقدمها في
شرقا تزامنا مع زياره زيلينسكي للجبهه
واعلان امريكي غربي عن حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده
في السودان الجيش يساعد ضربات الجويه على
مواقع للدعم السريع في الخرطوم المعارك
بين الحركه الشعبيه قطاع الشمال مع الجيش
تنتقل لاول مره من كردفان الى ولايه النيل
الازرق ومبادره الايجاد من وعود بالحل الى
ازمه جديده بعد ان اعتبر السودان بنودها
احتلالا الاتحاد الافريقي يؤكد دعمها
ويدعو لجعل الخرطوم منطقه منزوعه السلاح
في تصريحات مسربه من اجتماع بالكنيسه
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو يتحدث عن اجتثاف فكره
اقامه دوله فلسطينيه السلطه الفلسطينيه
تدين وتطالب بموقف امريكي جدي وحماس تدعو
السلطه لاعاده النظر في التزاماتها تجاه
الاحتلال بما في ذلك التنسيق الامني و
واشنطن تعبر عن انزعاجها من عرقله اسرائيل
حل الدولتين
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا حديث رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو عن اشتثاث
فكره اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه وقطع الطريق
على تطلعات الفلسطينيين لاقامتها
والاستطلاع ارائكم بهذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم كيف
سينعكس كلام نتنياهو على موقف المجتمع
الدولي من فكره حل الدولتين 30% توقعوا
ضغوطا دوليه تدفع حكومه نتنياهو لتغيير
ولو جزئي في موقفها بينما سبعون في المئه
فرجحوا ممارسه ضغوط لا تتجاوز التصريحات
السياسيه ولا تفلحوا في تغيير موقف
نتنياهو
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
ان الحمد
والنعمه لا
حجاج بيت الله الحرام يستعدون للوقوف
بعرفه غدا
في اول كلمه له بعد تصعيد الذي نفذته
مجموعه فاجنر قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
انه منذ بدايه الاحداث اتخذت سلطات
القرارات الضروريه بتحييد التهديدات
والدفاع عن التكوين الدستوري وحمايه
المواطنين للقضاء على ما سماه الانقلاب
المسلح متعهدا بجلبهم للعداله على حد
تعبيره
منذ بدايه الاحداث بشكل سريع اتخذنا
القرارات الضروريه بتحييد التهديدات
والدفاع عن التكوين الدستوري وحياه
المواطنين
الانقلاب المسلح كان
سيقضى عليه في كل الاحوال وبغض النظر عن
ان بعض التشكيلات التي فقدت عقلها كانت
تفهم كل شيء بما فيه الذين قاموا باعمال
اجراميه كادت ان تؤدي لتقسيم المجتمع في
ظل التهديدات الخارجيه
واضاف بوتين ان من وصفهم بمنظم التمرد
ارتكبوا خيانه بحق الوطن والمواطنين لسفك
الدماء وهو ما يريده من وصفهم بالنازيين
في كيف وسادتهم الغربيين على حد تعبيره
بوتن قال لمقاتل مجموعه فاغنر وطني وقال
انه مخيرون بعد الازمه بين توقيع عقود مع
الجيش او مغادره البلاد نحو بيلاروسيا
منظمين التمرد الذين خانوا الوطن والشعب
خانوا ايضا الذين جروهم وراءهم ودفعوهم
للموت ولنار ليطلقوا النار على ابناء
الجلدهم ان
السفك الدماء بين الاخوه هذا ما كان يريده
النازيون في كييف وسياداتهم الغربيه كانوا
يريدون ان يقوم الجنود الروس بقتل بعضهم
البعض حتى يقتل الجنود والمدنيين حتى تفشى
الروسي في النهايه وتهزم
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عقد
اجتماع عمل بمشاركه رؤساء هيئات انفاذ
القانون واضاف نابوتين بعد القاء خطابه
يعقد حاليا اجتماع عمل بمشاركه المدعي
العام الروسي
ووزير الداخليه فلاديمير
ووزير الدفاع
ومدير جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الكسندر
بورتنيكوف ورئيس الحرس الوطني فيكتور
زلاتوف ورئيس لجنه التحقيق الكسندر
باستريكن من جهته قال قائد المجموعه
ان الهدف من تحركه لم يكن الانقلاب على
السلطه المنتخبه قانونيا بل منع حل قوات
فاجنر ولفت الانتباه الى هذا الامر
واما وزير الخارجيه الروسيه فقال ان اجهزه
الامن الروسيه تبحث ما اذا كان
للاستخبارات الغربيه ضلع في احداث 24
من يونيو بحث تستبرقه واشنطن بالتصريح
بانه تعتبر ما حدث في روسيا شان داخليا
وان لا يدى لها به
انتهى التحرك العسكري لمجموعه فاغنر
وتنفست روسيا السعداء او هكذا يبدو على
الاقل غير ان الضباب لم ينقشع تماما عن
الحادث الامني الاخطر في روسيا خلال ربع
قرن من مكان غير معلوم خرج مالك المجموعه
يفجعيني بريجوجين عن صمته موضحا مسعاه مما
حدث يوم السبت الماضي
القرار ان نقوم بالعوده كان على اساس
عاملين اساسيين الاول هو اننا ما كنا نريد
ان نسفك الدماء الروسيه العامل الثاني كنا
قد خرجنا لنظهر اعتراضنا وليس بهدف ان
نسقط النظام في الدوله
يتعلق الامر اذا وفق بريكوجين بما يمكن
اعتباره تحركا لانقاذ فاغنر من قرار
بتفكيكها رغم ما قدمته للمجهود الحربي
الروسي في اوكرانيا ويبدو ان المجموعه
استشعرت الخطر على مستقبلها بعد توقيع
الرئيس بوتين قرارا يقضي بالزام المجموعات
العسكريه المقاتله مع الجيش بابرام عقود
مع وزاره الدفاع يجعلها تحت امره الوزير
سيرجي شويجو وهو من صاعت له مجموعه احمد
الشيشانيه ورفضته فاجنر وقد كان لافتا في
تصريحات قائد فاجنر الجديده حديثه عن
الدعم والتاييد لقواته في المناطق التي
دخلتها لاسيما مدينه روستوف حيث حياها
السكان بحماس وقدموا لها الورود بينما
اطلقوا صيحات استهجان في وجه دوريات
الشرطه بعد مغادره قوات فاغنر المدينه
يطرح ذلك اسئله ربما انت طموحات بريكوجين
ورسائله المبطنه وما اذا كانت التسويه
التي تمت بواسطه الرئيس البيلاروسي قد
حركت نوازع السلطه والسيطره في نفس الرجل
القوي المتجرئ دوما على المؤسسه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوج الحرب
نذهب الى موسكو وينضب الينا من هناك مدير
مكتبه الجزيره زاورش زاور بين حديث الرئيس
الروسي لاول مره بعدما جرى في الرابع
والعشرين من هذا الشهر
وحديث الكريم بان الرئيس بوتين يجري
اجتماعات عمل بمشاركه رؤساء هيئات انفاذ
القانون ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
طبعا فورا انتهاء كلمتها التي سجلها يعني
قبل الساعه من بثها فقط بدا باجتماع مع
قاده الاجهزه الامنيه ربما لوضع الخطوات
العمليه لتنفيذ ما تحدث عنه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اليوم بوتين كان واضحا
بتوصيف ما جرى بانه خيانه
وربما وسائل الاعلام الروسيه سلمى منذ
جرت احداث الرابعه والعشرين من يونيو كانت
تحاول ان تتصدر
نشراتها بكلمه او سؤال طرح لبوتين ما الذي
يمكن ان لا تغفر عنه قال الخيانه وبالتالي
واضح ان بوتين لا ينوي ان يغفر لخيانه
بريجوجن بدرجه الاولى هذا الشخص الذي كان
مقربا بشكل او باخر
وخلال كلمته ايضا ارسل باشارات الى ما
يسمى المعارضه الخارجيه وتحديدا
الماليه الموجوده في الخارج والتي تضررت
ربما اكثر من في روسيا من تداعيات هذه
الحرب في اوكرانيا بوتين وضع خيارات ثلاثه
لمقاتلي فاقدين مقاتلي الذين في معظمهم
ليسوا خروجي سجون كما يحاولون ان يدعون
مقاتلون وجنود وضباط سابقون جزء قليل منهم
في بدايه الحرف في اوكرانيا تم استقداد
اقدامهم بعقود من السجون وبوتين اعرب عن
شكره لاولئك الذين وصفهم بالوطنين وضعا
امامهم ثلاثه خيارات اما توقيع عقود مع
وزاره الدفاع ومؤسسات امنيه اخرى
والمساهمه في الحرب اوكرانيا او العوده
الى الاهل الى الحياه المدنيه وتسليم
سلاحهم او الذهاب الى بيلاروسيا كل
الخيارات مطروحه ولكن الذهاب الى
بيلاروسيا ربما هذا يطرح اسئله كثيره ايضا
كي هل ستكون فاينر عباء على سلطات
البيلاروسيه قبل قليل تناولت وسائل
الاعلام او لنقل مواقع عسكريه روسيه
معروفه لها مصداق عن عبور مقاتليه فاقدر
قوافل فاقدر بعتادها واسلحتها الكامله الى
داخل الاراضي البيلاروسيه هذا ان صدق
الخبر فهو يعني ان قسم كبير انتقل الى
بيلاروسيا ويبقى سؤال الاهم ما سيكون بعد
ذلك سيما وانا رئيس بيلاروسيا وعد
بريغوجين بان يكون عمل الاطار القانوني
ممكنا في حال لم يستمر بسيرته نحو موسكو
سلمى شكرا لك مكتبنا من موسكو
ونبقى في موسكو ينضم الينا من هناك سفير
اندريه نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين
الروسي مرحبا بك معنا
عندما يتحدث الرئيس بوتن
بالنما جرى
منظمي عمليات فاجنر تحديدا
وصفهم بانهم قاموا بانقلاب مسلح وابتزاز
هل كان يعني بذلك المنظمين اي من راس
الهرم الى اخر جندي وقف مع بريكوجين
في الواقع
منذ ساعه السيد بوتين في كلمته
قام بتفسير اخر لما حدث
قال ان اغلبيه الجنود
في هذه التشكيلات العسكريه حاربوا بشجاعه
وقوه على الجبهات ضد
النظام الفاشي في كييف وقال انهم اظهروا
بطوله غير مسبوقه هناك وانه يعتقد ان
اغلبيه من كانوا في قوات فاغنر استطاعوا
ان يقوموا بخيار سريع وصحيح وان لا يلحق
طموح القائد الذي واقعيه قام
بجريمه ضد الدوله علما انه ما كان يقصد
هذا اريد ان اشرح واوضح ان وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه الان ينظرون بسوء اللي ما حدث
لنقرا داخليا بعيدا عن ما داخليا في روسيا
نريد ان نفهم اكثر ما الذي اعناه الرئيس
الروسي بوتين عندما تحدث بان منظمي عمليات
فاجنر خانو الوطن وانهم سيجلبون الى
العداله اليس هذا يناقض اتفاق الرابع
والعشرين من يونيو
فهمتي الموضوع بشكل خاطئ وما قاله السيد
بوتين لقد اكد
استعداد
لاستقبال اغلب قوات فاجنر في صفوف الجيش
النظامي الروسي هل هذا متابعه لهم كلا هذا
ضمان ان كل من ادرك خطاه
ثم عاد عن هذه الاعمال اي محاوله الهجوم
على موسكو
الانقلاب كما تحدث الرئيس الروسي منظمي
الانقلاب هل هذا يعني بان بريجوجن بحسب
توصيف الرئيس الروسي هو خائن وسيجب الى
العداله هل يفهم ذلك
كلا ليس كما قلت ليس هذا الادراك السليم
هناك اتفاق وصلوا له
لحلحله المسائل لان الرئيس البيروسي السيد
لوكاشنكا سوف
طلب ان توقف اي دعوات قضائيه على
او كل من قاموا بهذه الاعمال التي تعتبر
خيانه حقيقيا ان جماعات بريغوجين كان
لديهم اسلوب اخر في القيام بالاعمال
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وبالنسبه للنيتو منذ
البدايه كان لديهم
موقفا صارما
واذا
بما ان هذه هذا الموقف كان معتمدا من
الوزاره لو ان الوزاره اخذت بعين الاعتبار
اعمل
لكانوا وصلوا للكيف ولا اشكرك نتوقف عند
هذه النقطه من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا لك
وينضم الينا من
مدير مجلس حوار منسك للعلاقات الدوليه
مرحبا بك معنا هل الاتفاق السبت لا زال
متماسك من حيث ضمان
عدم محاكمه
في القافله المتجهه باتجاه موسكو واسقاط
الدعاوى بعد اسقاط الدعوه القضائيه التي
كانت بحقهم في ذلك اليوم بعد حديث بوتين
الليله
ما اتصوره انه حتى الان كل شيء بقي على
اوضاعه
القديمه على الاتفاق
سوف ننظر للاجراءات السياسيه التي سوف تقع
في روسيا حتى الان ليس هناك اي مؤشرات ان
يقوموا بنقد هذا الاتفاق الذي كان في
السبت
ضمن هذه الخيارات المطروحه من قبل
الكرملين ايضا لمجموعه اما الانضمام الى
اجهزه الدفاع والاجهزه الامنيه الاخرى او
يعني ترك العمل المسلح والذهاب الى الحياه
المدنيه او التوجه الى بيلاروسيا هل مثل
هذا الامر يعني ممكن استيعابه في
بيلاروسيا
[موسيقى]
بما انه بيروسيا قدمت نفسها على انها وسيط
وطرف ضمان هذا يعني انه
الشكل الشكل الذي سوف يضمن هذه الاتفاقات
هذه الاشكال قد تكون مختلفه تماما لاننا
لا نعرف كل التفاصيل عن هذه الاتفاقات
المبرمه ولكنني اعتقد ان حتى الطرف
البيروسي انطلاقا مما سمعناه في الاعلام
مسبقا اثبتت انها سوف تقوم بالالتزام بهذه
الاتفاقات وان ميلسك سوف تعمل في التوجهات
المبرمه على الاتفاق المهم هنا ان روسيا
هي في
اجراءات وعمليات سياسيه ولا ننتظر اي امور
غير متوقعه ونحن لسنا في طور تغيير اي
اتفاقات شكرا لك
مدير مجلس حوار منسك للعلاقات الدوليه
شكرا على المشاركه معنا
وفي التعليق الامريكي كما اشرنا قبل قليل
اكدت واشنطن عادم ضلوعها في الاحداث التي
شهدت روسيا وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه
انما حدث يعد شانا داخليا مؤكدا اجراء
بلاده اتصالات مع المسؤولين الروس في هذا
الشان
فاجنر ومستقبلها في روسيا وما وراء الحدود
الروسيه هو موضوع سنناقشه اكثر في فقرات
في المتابعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
في اول ظهور له منذ تصعيد فاجنر ضد
المؤسسه العسكريه في روسيا تفقد وزير
الدفاع الروسي مركز القياده الاماميه
بمجموعه قوات الغربه المشاركه في الحرب
على اوكرانيا ياتي هذا في وقت تتحدث فيه
كيف عن تقدم تحرزه قواتها في الشرق
والجنوب في مقابل روايه روسيه تنفي هذا
التقدم
تقدم اوكراني في معارك الجبهه الشرقيه وان
كان بوتيره بطيئه بلده بث الاوكرانيون
منها هذه الصور معلنين استعادتها وانهاء
السيطره الروسيه عليها هذه البلله الصغيره
جنوب غربي حدود مقاطعه زباروديا هي البلده
التاسعه التي استعادها الاوكرانيون في
الاسابيع الاخيره تقول نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان قواتهم نفذت هجوما مضادا
خلال اسبوع في عده محاور وحققت تقدما في
كل اتجاه يراوح بين كيلو متر وكيلو مترين
بمساحه قدرتها ب 130 كيلومترا مربعا
الروايه الروسيه المقابله من وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت بدورها عن صد الهجمات الاوكرانيه
شرقا وتكميد قواتها خسائر كبيره في الجنود
والعتاد جنوبا يبرز تمكن الاوكرانيين من
العبور الى الضفه اليمنى لنهر دينيبر
تطورا لافتا وسابقا من نوعه منذ تراجع
الروسي باتجاه هذه الضفه في مقاطعه خرسون
نهايه العام الماضي عبور نهر دنيبر يعطي
الاوكرانيين طرقا مختصره في حال تامين
الضفتين في منطقه ما وانشائهم جسورا تعبر
منها القوات نهر دنيبر الفاصل والعائق
الطبيعي بين الطرفين عندها تصبح المواجهه
مباشره اكثر بعدما كان الاوكرانيون يركزون
على استهداف الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات
الروسيه الروايه الروسيه ذكرت ان مجموعات
اوكرانيه صغيره حاولت عبور النهر بالقوارب
الا ان قواتهم استهدفتها ودمرتها ومع
التركيز الاوكراني ثم يطلق عليه الهجوم
المضاد جنوبا وشرقا وتقدمهم على حساب
الروسي وفق ما يقولون ما زال الميدان يقبل
احتمالات كثيره وربما كبيره اذ ظهر وزير
الدفاع الروسي متفقدا احد المواقع في
رساله بعوده التركيز العسكري الروسي على
ما يحدث في اوكرانيا بعد الانشغال داخليا
لوقت قصير كما ان وسائل اعلام روسيه بثت
صورا قالت انها لمقاتلي مجموعه فاجنر في
مقاطعه لوجانس باوكرانيا عقب انسحابها من
الاراضي الروسيه
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي وفايز مرحبا بك معنا
ما هو حجم التقدم الذي ترصده والذي تتحدث
عنه اوكرانيا وتنفيه روسيا خاصه بعدما وقع
في يوم السبت الفائت في موسكو
يعني الان بعد تقريبا ما يقارب
اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع من بدء الهجوم
المضاد الانجازات لم ترقى الى حجم
التوقعات
وتحدث عن ذلك
الاوكران
ومراكز الدراسات ومركز دراسات الحرب الى
غير ذلك لكن هناك انجاز محدود انجاز
التعبير تم السيطره على ثمن بلدات مساحه
130 كيلو متر مربع
خفت مستوى
العمليات العسكريه في جبروجيا
تصاعدت تحديدا في باك موت
ومارينكا
واليمان لكن السؤال هل هذا هو الهجوم
المضاد الرئيسي اما نزال نتحدث عن المرحله
الاولى التي تمثل عمليات جسم نبض وتحقيق
موضع قدم وفتح الثغرات من اجل حدوث الهجوم
الرئيسي لماذا اقول هذا الكلام
اريد ان اعرج قبل يعني وقت المقابله هو
ضيق واريد ان نفهم منك في عجاله ايضا
بالنسبه لي
اتفاقيه نقل المجموعات التابعه التي لا
تريد الانضمام لقوات الدفاع الروسيا او
اجهزه الامن الروسيه الى بيلاروسيا هل هو
امر من الناحيه العسكريه امر سهل ان تذهب
باتجاه بيلاروسيا وتتحمل بلا روسيا مثل
هذا العبء العسكري المقاتلين على جبهات
كانوا قبل ايام هناك
السؤال الاخطر
اذا ما تم نقلها ما هي المهام التي ستسند
لها هنا السؤال الاخطر هل سيتم نقلها
لتكون قاعده ومنطقه حشد لها
لاستخدامها في افريقيا ام ستكون رئيس حربه
لهجوم من بيلاروسيا اذا طبيعه المهام
المستقبليه هي التي
ستبين ذلك اما ان تتواجد في لوغانسك او في
دونيس او في بيلاروسيا لها موازناتها لها
مخصصات لها اليه تدريبها واليه التعامل مع
لكن السؤال الخطير ما هي طبيعه المهام
المستقبليه اذا كانت طبيعه المهام
المستقبليه لاعاده توظيفها للقتال هذا
يعني فتح جبهه بيلاروسيا وبالتالي نعود
نتحدث عن الهجوم في شهر اشباط من العام
الماضي عندما كان الهجوم على العاصمه
واضافه لما تتحدث به لواء دويري بريغوجين
اليوم يكشف ترتيبات لمواصله نشاط قواته
ويتكتم عن التفاصيل نشاط قواته انطلاقا من
بيلاروسيا يعني كيف
تصوراتك لمثل هذا النشاط والى اي درجه
يمكن ان يشكل وجودهم على
لوكاشينكو الرئيس البيلاروسي
يعني الان اذا اذا اذا تم نقلها واذا
ارادت روسيا توظيفها في عمليات عسكريه
جديده الان تصبح بلا روسيا مشتركه مباشره
بالحرب وبالتالي هذا الامر قد يرقى الى
مستوى خطير جدا اذا ما اخذنا بتصريحات
لوكاشينكو عندما تحدث اي عدوان على بلادي
فيمكن ان استخدم السلاح النووي لانه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وقبل حركه بريكوجن تم
الحديث عن نقل سلاح نووي تكتيكي وبالتالي
هل هذا الامر حقيقه تم تنفيذه هل هو تحت
سيطره
ام تحت سيطره الكرملين اذا هذا يفتح افاق
جديده للصراع وخاصه ان بيلاروسيا هي دوله
تحاذ العديد من دول اصلا اعضاء في الفنيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان لواء فايزه دويرق
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا ايضا اعلنا مفاوض
السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف
في ختام اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اقرار حزمه مساعدات بقيمه 3.5
مليارات يورو لاوكرانيا ولتغطيه جود
السلام في افريقيا والبلقان ودول اخرى
[موسيقى]
رجع فقط
الى السودان حيث تتسع رقعه المعارك بشكل
لافت اذ هاجمت الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان الشمال بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو
هاجمت مواقع للجيش السوداني في ولايه
النيل الازرق في الاثناء تستمر الاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في العاصمه
الخرطوم تفاصيل المشهد الميداني في
التقرير التالي
يخشى ان الامور تتجه لمزيد من التصعيد في
السودان مع توسع رقعه القتال ولايه النيل
الازرق تشهد التطورات الاحدث حيث انتقل
اليها لاول مره الاشتباك المباشر بين
الجيش والحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان
شمال التي يقودها عبد العزيز الحلو
تواصل الحركه هجماتها على مواقع الجيش
السوداني جنوب مدينه الكرموك وتحدثت مصادر
من الجيش بان القوات المسلحه تتصدى
للهجمات وبحسب المصادر فان الحركه تستهدف
بالقصف ايضا مناطق في الاقليم وكانت
المعارك بين الجانبين بدات قبل اسابيع في
ولايه جنوب كردفان خاض الجيش السوداني
قتالا على محور مشتبك فيه مع الحركه في
محيط كادوبلي عاصمه الولايه وفي مدينه
الدلنج واخر شمال الولايه بينه وبين الدعم
السريع في معسكر طيبه التابع للجيش
السوداني بمدينه الدبيبات وفي ولايه شمال
كردفان تبقى مدينه الاوبيض محور المعارك
بين الدعم السريع والجيش بدورها تشتعل
ولايات اقليم دارفور بمعارك مستمره اعنفها
تلك التي شهدتها مدينه الجنينه بولايه غرب
دارفور والتي اسفرت عن اوضاع الانسانيه
بالغه السوء اما العاصمه فلم يتوقف القتال
فيها منذ الدلاع الازمه الناطق الرسمي
باسم الجيش السوداني اكد ان قوات الدعم
السريع استولت على مقر رئاسه شرطه
الاحتياط المركزي جنوبي
ونشرت قوات الدعم السريع صورا قالت انها
من داخل المقر بعد السيطرتها عليه
بالاثناء افاد مراسل الجزيره بتحليق طائره
عسكريه واطلاق نار متقطع بجنوب شرق
الخرطوم بالتزامن مع سماع اصوات اسلحه
ثقيله غربيه المدينه وسمع ذوي انفجارات
متقطعه جنوبيه مدينتي انظر معي
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والسوداني سيد
ضياء مرحبا بك معنا في المعطى الميداني
قراءه الوضع في العاصمه السودانيه خاصه
بعد السيطره قوات الدعم السريع على مقر
الشرطه الاحتياطي في الخرطوم وايضا
التحركات للحركه الشعبيه الشمال بقياده
عبد العزيز الحلو اين يضع الجيش والمعارك
في السودان نعم يبدو ان هذه محاوره لشد
الاطراف باعتبار ان هذه الحركه حركه
الشعبيه لتحرير تحاول ان تستغل الوضع
العسكري والانشغال الجيش بالمعارك الدائره
في الخرطوم لتفتح جبهات اخرى لتستحوذ على
بعض المناطق ويبدو ان هذه هي نوع من انواع
الانتهازيه السياسيه او الانتهازيه
العسكريه بان تستغل هذه هذا الظرف لتحقيق
بعض المكاسب العسكريه الوضع في في العاصمه
هي يوميات الحرب انتكاسات وانتصارات
بالنسبه للجيش صحيح ما حدث هو انتكاس
عسكريه ولكن اعتقد ان الجيش لا يدل ممسك
بزمام المبادره وهو لا يزال يحافظ على
الاماكن الاستراتيجيه المواقع
الاستراتيجيه السبع الموجوده في العاصمه
وهي مقراته الاساسيه ولم يستطع تستطيع
الدعاء يستطيع الدعم السريع ان يصل الى
هذه الاماكن
القوات الدعم السريع على مقر الشرطه نعم
هذا مقر شرطه وليس مقر قتالي بالدرجه
الاولى ولكنه يمكن ان يفتح الطريق امام
مكان اخر مهم بالنسبه للجيش وهو المدرعات
وكذلك هنالك سلاح الذخيره هذه اسلحه حساسه
ومؤثره واستراتيجيه بالنسبه للجيش خطر
السيطره على هذا المكان هو بانه يمكن ان
يكون مقدمه
للتحركات نحو هذه الاماكن سيد نذهب
لنستطلع اكثر خريطه الطريق التي عرضتها
منظمه الايجاد ففي اول تعليق من الاتحاد
الافريقي على خارطه طريق منظمه ايجاد لحل
النزاع في السودان اعلنا مجلس الامن
والسلم الافريقي تاييده الخطه بالكامل
وطلب المجلس بتجريد العاصمه الخرطوم من
السلاح فورا وبوقف غير مشروط للاعمال
العدائيه يتعرض موقف مجلس الامن والسلم مع
الموقف الرسمي السوداني الذي عبر عنه في
وقت سابق مالك عقار نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده والذي وصف مبادره ايجاد بمبادره
احتلال
تشتد المعارك في السودان بشكل يجعل الحاجه
الى حل دبلوماسي اكثر الحاحا واستعجالا في
هذه الاجواء يصدر مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي بيانا يعلن فيه تاييده الكامل
لخطه منظمه ايجاد لحل النزاع في السودان
ويطالب بتجريد العاصمه الخرطوم من السلاح
فورا وبوقف غير مشروط للاعمال العدائيه من
ابرز مهام مجلس السلم والامن المكون من
خمسه عشره دوله دعم الدبلوماسيه الوقائيه
وصنع السلام وتعزيز التنسيق بين الاليات
الاقليميه فيما يتعلق بالسلام لكن تاييده
لخطه ايجاد يطرح اكثر من علامات استفهام
من اهمها لماذا هذا الموقف بعد ان اعلن
مالك عقار نائب مجلس سياده السوداني رفض
الخطه لانها تنص على ادخال قوات دويه الى
الخرطوم ووصفها بخطه احتلال يشير كلام
عقار الى رفض دخول قوات دوليه الى الخرطوم
باعتباره مسا بسياده السودان
يتحدث من منطلق ان الجيش الوطني السوداني
هو حامي هذه السياده وانه من غير المعقول
مطالبته بالخروج من عاصمه البلاد وهنا
تبرز علامه استفهام اخرى وهي لماذا
الخرطوم دون غيرها مع العلم ان الحربه
تدور ايضا في دارفور والفاشر وغيرهما رفض
مالك عقار رئاسه كينيا للجنه الرباعيه
لايجاد واتهمها بعدم الحياد بينما تنص
الخطه التي اعلن مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي تاييده لها على ان تستضيف كينيا
عمليه سياسيه شامله من اجل تحقيق سلام
مستدام وانتقال سلمي الى الديمقراطيه
والحكم المدني هنا تبرز علامه استفهام
اخرى وهي كيف يدعم المجلس استضافه دوله هي
كينيا للعمليه السياسيه التي ستؤدي الى
الحل وهو يعرف ان احد طرفي النزاع يتهمها
بعدم الحياد اذا رمى مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي بثقله وراء خطه ايجاد ويبقى
انتظاره تاثير ذلك على جهود الحل المتعثره
حتى الان
سيد ضياء الدين مع التاييد مجلس السلم
والامن الذي يمثل الاتحاد الافريقي
لخطه الايجاد ما الذي بقي من خيارات
السودان الرسمي ولطرفي النزاع
هي قائمه حبات
موضوع الاجراء المتعلق بان السودان لم
يستشر في هذه في هذه المبادره ولا في هذه
التفاصيل وكانه منزوعه للسياده ومنزوع
الاراده تريد هذه الاطراف ان تملي عليه
وذلك ما لم يحدث في تجارب اخرى مثل
التجربه الاثيوبيه التي رفضت التدخل
الايجارات والتدخل الاتحاد الافريقي ووجدت
تبريرات وقبول من قبل موسى فكي في الاتحاد
الافريقي فاعتقد ان هذا هذا محاوله
لاستصغار الشان السوداني ومحاوله لفرض
وصايا على السودان واملاء بعض الشروط
حينما تتحدثين عن نزع السلاح هذا يعني انك
راغب في نزعه السياده
هذه هذا جيش دوله محترف به دوله محترف بها
دوله لا تقاتل اطراف لها لها شرعيه تقاتل
اطراف تمردت عليها تمردت عليها وهذه
الاطراف لم تعد اطراف سودانيه التقارير
والمعلومات كلها كشفت بانها قوات الدعم
السريع الان اصبحت قوات عابر الحدود تاتي
من اماكن مختلفه تاتي من مالي وتاتي من
النيجر وتاتي من تشاء شكرا لك في
الاستوديو ضيفنا ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني
في تصريح مسرب من اجتماع بالكنيست قال
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو انه يجب
العمل على اشتثاث فكره اقامات الدوله
الفلسطينيه يتزامن هذا مع اقرار السلطات
الاسرائيليه بناء 5000 وحده استيطانيه
جديده في الضفه الرئاسه الفلسطينيه دانت
تلك التصريحات وقالت انها تظهر نيه
اسرائيل الرافضه للشرعيه الدوليه كما
تلابط واشنطن بالتعامل مع مواقف نتنياهو
بجديه اما حركات حماس فدعت القياده
الفلسطينيه الى اعاده النظر في المسار
التفاوضي ووقف التنسيق الامني مع الاحتلال
لم يقل جديدا فمتى امن بنيامين نتنياهو
بحل الدولتين ربما احتاج لطمانه اشد
المتطرفين من قاده المستوطنين ومن شركائه
في الحكومه بان رؤيته تنسجم مع رؤىهم انه
يثبت هنا الرغبه في اجتثاف فكره اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه
تلك تصريحات تقول رئاسه الفلسطينيه انها
تظهر انه لا يوجد شريك اسرائيلي يريد
تحقيق السلام القائمه على الشرعيه الدوليه
وتطالب الاداره الامريكيه بالتعامل مع
مواقف الرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي في هذا
الشان بجديه
اما حركه حماس فتدعو القياده الفلسطينيه
لاعاده النظر في مسار المفاوضات ووقف
التنسيق الامني مع الاحتلال لكن ماذا ابقى
التل ابيب لحل الدولتين حتى تجتفاه
يقضي هذا المبدا بالاعتراف بدوله فلسطينيه
ذات السياده على حدود عام
1967 اي الحدود التي كان عليها الحال قبل
الخامس من حزيران يونيو من ذلك العام
وتشمل الضفه الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه اضافه
الى قطع غزه
اليوم وفي ظل ما فرضته اسرائيل من وقائع
على الارض بدا حل الدولتين كانه بلا معنى
فالمناطق المصنفه في اتفاق اوسلو الثاني
الف وباء بالضفه الغربيه مقسمه ومجزاه
بطرق وقواعد اسرائيليه كما ان النشاط
الاستيطاني لا ينفك فيها يتوسع
بوصفه صاحب اطول فترات الحكم في رئاسه
وزراء اسرائيل كان بنيامين نتنياهو اكثر
من اضروا بحل الدولتين اعترف مره واحده
عام 2009 بحق الفلسطينيين في دوله لهم تحت
ضغوط من نضاره الرئيس الامريكي انذاك
باراك اوباما لكنه وضع للامر شروطا
تعجيزيه
ثم سخر حكوماته كافه لتعزيز المشروع
الاستيطاني في القدس ومدن الضفه الغربيه
المحتله هكذا تم عزل مدينه القدس تماما عن
جسد الضفه
وجرح حتى عام 2021 قدم نحو 40% من مساحه
الضفه الغربيه لصالح المستوطنات كما اسهمت
شبكه الطرق الالتفافيه التي اقيمت بطول
980 كيلومترا في اختراق المناطق
الفلسطينيه وتقطيع اوصال القرى الفلسطينيه
بالضفه
انه تقطيع لاوصال الدوله الفلسطينيه
المستقبليه ونهش للاراضي المفترض ان تقام
عليها
الحقيقه انني نتنياهو ظل دوما من اشد
المعارضين لاقامه تلك الدوله اما الصراع
مع الفلسطينيين فلا يقدم رؤيه سياسيه لحله
وانما لادارته فهو يؤمن بالسلام الاقتصادي
سلام لا يتعارض وفقا لرؤيته مع الابقاء
على السلطه الفلسطينيه ولا مع التطبيع مع
دول عربيه لكن دون مقابل قد يجني
الفلسطينيون ثمره
هذا ودانا الخارجيه الامريكيه جميع اعمال
العنف المتطرف والتحريض عليه سواء من
الاسرائيليين او الفلسطينيين وقالت نواطن
ثابته في عملها لتعزيز خفض تصعيد كما
وصفات الخارجيه الامريكيه المستوطنات
بالعائق امام محل الدولتين المتفاوض عليه
وقالت انها تنقل ذلك بشكل مباشر الى
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين واوضحت الخارجيه
الامريكيه معارضتها الاجراءات التي قالت
انها تجعل تحقيق حل الدولتين اكثر صعوبه
وتشكل عقبه امام السلام وعربه عن قلقها
اذا اقرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه المضيف في
خططي بناء اكثر من 4000 مستوطنه في الضفه
الغربيه
ينضم الينا من رام الله دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه دكتور مصطفى مرحبا بك معنا حتى
وان كان حديث يعني اقامه حل الدولتين هو
حديث منزوع المعنى بسبب ما يجري حقيقه على
ارض الواقع وايضا المواقف الدوليه الرخوه
ازاءه ما تتصرف به اسرائيل لمنع تحقيق
الدولتين فعليا
ما غرض نتنياهو من الذهاب الى حديث عن
اشتثاث الفكره من اصلها
هذا ليس جديدا على نتنياهو لانه اصلا منذ
عام 1994 كتب كتابا اسمه مكان تحت الشمس
ناقش فيه كيفيه القضاء على فكره الدوله
مستقله فلسطينيه
ودعا الى تدمير اتفاق اوسلو على علته
ومنذ ذلك الحين هو يسير في هذا الاتجاه
الشيء الجديد انه يقود الان حكومه ليست
فقط عنصريه متطرفه بالحكومه ارهابيه مجرمه
ومعه ارهابيون فاشيون من طراز بن جبير
وسموتريتش واليوم هو يريد ان يترجم اقواله
ليس فقط بمنع واشتثاف فكره اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله بل يريد ان يقضي على
الوجود الفلسطيني في ارض فلسطين التاريخيه
بشكل عام وهذا هو سر ما يجري الان من توسع
استيطاني يريد ان يضيفوا الى 151 مستعمره
استيطانيه غير شرعيه 170 مست عمره جديده
والان اعلن عن الاف الوحدات الاستيطانيه
الجديده اذا نحن امام هجمه لا تشمل فقط
الاستيطان بل محاوله التطهير العرقي ايضا
ضمن حديثي اليوم المسرب يعني اني يعني ما
خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه خاصه بانه تحدث
بانه يريد الحفاظ عليها لاداء وظيفتها كما
سمى كما سماها نتنياهو ما هي الخيارات وهي
لا زالت تؤمن بانه يجب الذهاب الى حل
الدولتين
اولا انا براينا على فكره حل الدولتين
وهدفه من التطبيع مع الدول العربيه كان ان
يتجاوز حل الدولتين وحق الفلسطينيين في
الاستقلال الوطني
ولكن اليوم الذي نواجهه واقع جديد واقع
دوله واحده بنظام ابرتيت عنصري وما يجب ان
يقال لنا نتنياهو ان دوله واحده بنظام
افرتايد عنصري لا يمكن ان يرضخ لها الشعب
الفلسطيني بل بديلها الوحيد هو دوله
ديمقراطيه على كامل الارض فلسطين
التاريخيه مع اسقاط كل نظام الابرتيد
العنصري الصهيوني السلطه الفلسطينيه ما
زالت متردده تراوح في مكانها للاسف الشديد
وتتعلق باهداف ما خشن وهو اتفاق اوسلو انا
برايي المطلوب من السلطه الفلسطينيه خاصه
ان نتنياهو قال انه لا يريد دوله يريد ان
يشترثها ولكن يريد ان يبقي السلطه
الفلسطينيه كوكيل امني له انا برايي الان
السلطه الفلسطينيه مطالبه بان تعلن تخليها
عن اسلوب الكامل الذي قتله نتنياهو ان
تعلن الغاء ووقف كل اشكال التنسيق الامني
مع اسرائيل ان تطالب العالم وخاصه
الولايات المتحده بفرض عقوبات ومقاطعه على
اسرائيل وكذلك مطالبه الدول العربيه بهذا
المصاري السابق فشل فشل ويجب الاعتراف
بانه فشل واختيار نهج جديد قائم على
الكفاح والمقاومه والمطالبه بالمقاطعه من
رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بدات تصعيده حجيج بيت الله الحرام من
مشعري منى الى مشاري عرفات استعدادا
للوقوف بعرفه يوم غدا التاسع من ذي الحجه
وصحص استعدادات من الجهات الامنيه والصحيه
كافه العامله في خدمه الحجيج الذين يتوقع
ان يصل عددهم الى مليونين و300 الف حاج
وبدات السلطات الامنيه السعوديه تنفيذه
خطط تفويج ضيوف الرحمن الى مشعر عرفات
بتنسيق مع وزاره الحج والعمره
[موسيقى]
تعد اندونيسيا اكثر دول العالم تفويجا
للحجيج ويحج هذا العام 221 الف اندونيسي
وتعد رحله الحج بالنسبه للاندونيسيين حلما
ينتظرون تحققه بعد سنوات طويله من
الانتظار مستوى مغني واسرته انتظروا دورهم
لسنوات حتى سنحت لهم الفرصه هذا العام
الجزيره رافقت رحلتهم من منزلهم حتى
وصولهم الى مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
الجنوبيه جنوب غرب العاصمه الاندونيسيه
جاكرتا بالحجاج الذين يستعدون للتوجه الى
بلاد الحرمين ومنهم الحاج مستوى بن مغني
لقد انتظر هو وزوجته سلامه بنت شاعر اثني
عشر عاما جماعه
سفر الناس لاداء فريضه الحج ليس امرا سهلا
هناك من لديه القدره الماليه لكن حجه ظل
مؤجلا وانا شخصيا ليس لدي المال الكافي
لكن قدر الله ان اسافر للحج
اكبر الله اكبر
وكما كان الناس يودعون الحجاج في الماضي
عندما كانوا يستقلون السفن في رحله بحريه
تمتد شهور يؤذن في الحي اعلانا لموعد
انطلاق الحجاج
محمد وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد يجتمع الحجيج من كل انحاء المدينه
حيث ان لكل اقليم او مدينه او محافظه سجلا
منفصلا لقوائم انتظار الحجيج التي تمتد
بين احد عشر عاما وسبعه واربعين عاما
ويودع المسؤولون القافله
يتجمع بعد ذلك اغلبيه الحجاج لساعات او
لليله وربما اكثر في مجمعات سكن الحجاج
وقد شيدت اندونيسيا ثمانيه وعشرين مجمعا
للحجاج منذ عام 79
وتعطى الاولويه لكبار السن الذين يشكلون
ثلث حجاج اندونيسيا هذا
العامرين
من تجاوزت اعمارهم خمسه وستين عاما الحج
العام الماضي بسبب جائحه كورونا ومع رفع
القيود هذا العام لم تعد هناك شروط تخص
اعمار الحجاج لذلك فان الحكومه
الاندونيسيه تسعى جاهده الى خدمه كبار
السن ومنحهم اولويه وبعد نحو شهر من لقاء
الحاج مستوى بن مغني في منزله بمدينه
تانجر الجنوبيه باندونيسيا نلتقيه اليوم
في مكه المكرمه مع افراد اسرته العشره
الذين كتب لهم الحج هذا العام
اشعر بسعاده وراحه نفسيه لا توصف والحمد
لله لا انسى والد زوجتي الذي تكفل بنفقات
حجنا قبل وفاته وقد وجدنا مستوى طيبا
ومريحا من الخدمه وتسهيلات يكرر مستوى
بالمغني ومن معه عبارات الشكر على مجاوره
الحرمين الشريفين لاسابيع قبل الحج وقد
تمتد فتره اقامتهم لمثل ذلك بعد الحج
ويدعو الله ان يستطيع التكفل بحج ابنائه
واحفاده مع زياده السكانيه في كثير من
بلاد المسلمين لم تعد تاديه فريضه الحج
سريعه التحقق للملايين فلا يقتصر الامر
على القدره الماليه وحدها وسنوات الانتظار
تطول في بلد كاندونيسيا ومن يتحقق رجاؤه
باداء فريضه الحج تغمره السعاده شكرا لله
على نعمه الصلاه في بيته العتيق
طيب جاسم الجزيره
مكه المكرمه
بالعوده اذا الى ملف فاجنر والجدل بشان
مستقبلها نذكر بدايه بكيف بدات هذه الشركه
ظهرت فاقدر عام 2014 بعد ضم روسيا شبه
جزيره القرن وقد ظهرت كشركه امنيه خاصه
تقدر بعض اجهزه المخابرات الغربيه اعداد
جنودها باكثر من 50 الفا كثير منهم كانوا
سجناء سابقين بحسب صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
فان جذورها تعود الى شركه غامضه تاسست
تدعى الفيلق السلافي عام 2013 وكان خلف
تاسيس تلك الشركه الامنيه شخصيات مقربه من
النظام السوري اما المؤسسه المعلن لفايف
فهو رجل الاعمال الرجل الاعمال
وقد اخذت الشركه اسمها شهرتها من اسمه
الحركي فاجنر اما يفرجن فيعد مالك الشركه
لا يوجد اي وضع قانوني حتى اللحظه اللي
فاقنار لا في روسيا ولا في اي مكان في
العالم خاصه بان القانون الروسي يمنع قيام
الشركات الامنيه الخاصه فهي موجوده دون اي
سند قانونيه تنشط فاجنر في ثلاث قارات هي
امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا وايضا في اسيا
حيث توجد مناطق الصراع في كل من سوريا
وليبيا وافريقيا الوسطى مدغشقر موزمبيق
والسودان
ومالي ايضا لكن اسئله ملحه عن مستقبل شركه
فاجنر تظل ماثله فما الذي ينتظر مالك
الشركه ومقاتلها خلال الفتره القادمه فقد
اعلنت وزاره العدل الروسيه ان الملاحقات
القضائيه ضد بريجوجن لم تسقط رغم تضمين
اتفاق وقف التصعيد الغاء كل الملاحقات
القضائيه ضده اما المقاتلون فاعلنت
السلطات الروسيه نيتها دمجهم في وزاره
الدفاع حيث دعا وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو
كل مقاتلين غير الرسميين الى التواصل مع
وزارته لتوقيع عقودهم قبل الاول من يوليو
القادم وهو ما اكد عليه الرئيس الروسي
الليله بتخييرهم بين توقيع عقود مع الجيش
او الرحيل للمزيد ينضم الينا من لندن
الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك دكتور عمر معنى
مواقعيه هذه الحلول المطروحه لمقاتلي
فاجنر اما الانضمام الى الاجهزه اجهزه
وزاره الدفاع والاجهزه الامنيه او الذهاب
العوده للحياه المدنيه او الذهاب ببساطه
الى بيلاروسيا
هو ما بدا هذه الاشكاليه او مفجرها هو
موضوع الضم
للجيش النظامي الروسي لانه يعني واحد
القياده القياده
ستكون مهدده بهذه الطريقه هو كان يضع نفسه
راس راس مع وزير الدفاع
وكان الى حد ما
يعني ينتقل بشكل رسمي وعلني وكان احيانا
يعاقب بعض قاده الالويه كما حدث قائد 72
في حين حقق معه يعني منظم كانه شرطه
عسكريه فبالتالي هذه الاستقلاليه من ناحيه
من ناحيه الراس واضحه للغايه من ناحيه
الجنود الجنود عدد كبير من جنود كانوا في
الجيش النظامي وخرجوا من الجيش النظامي
بتاديب بتاديب على مستوى الاخلاقي لانه
هناك ارتكب وانتهاكاد الكثير منهم ينظرون
الجيش النظامي على انه جيش غير فعال وانهم
اكفا منه بكثير وهو بعض الاداءات في
الميدان تثبت ذلك او احيانا حسب حسب حسب
المعركه
فين قانونيه للغايه له المال طبعا يدفعون
اكثر بكثير فيما يخص الراتب الرواتب وفيما
يخص المكافات وخاصه الانشطه الخارجيه
كثيره ايضا العقود سته اشهر انت تدخل
الجيش ولا تعرف اين استخرج اليوم وحتى هو
الجيش لم يحترم العقود التي وقعها بعد
وهذا ينقلنا الدكتور عمر لسؤال مستقبل هذه
الشركه خاصه بان اليوم تحدث بانه سيواصل
نشاطاته دون الحديث عن التفاصيل هل
باستطاعتي ان يكمل النشاطات من بيلاروسيا
يمكن طبعا هو هو المشكله لم تنحل يعني انا
لا ارى هذه التسويه حلت يعني حتى
الشروط التسويه هذه غير واضحه والشروط
التي اعلنت تقريبا
اهملت في اليوم الذي يليه
تقول انه لا توجد ايه اسقاط للعقوبات على
في جوجل
ازمه الضمه هذه هي هي التي فجرت موضوع
التمرد او محاولات الانقلاب كما تسمى
احيانا
فبالتالي خروجه الى بيلاروسيا لا يعني
الكثير حقيقه لا يعني سواء انه يعني موقع
القياده سيكون مختلف طبعا هو لا اظن انه
ايضا ساذج يعني يخرج الى ممكن ان ينتهي في
بيلاروس يعني فهو يريد ان يكون بين قواته
وبين جنوده واليوم هذه الحركه
الدراماتيكيه التي ظهرت وهو يتكلم وخلفه
المقابر
يعني مقابر قتلر ويتكلم عن انه انه
حقنا الدماء وطبعا الدماء لان الحركه كانت
دمويه للغايه هو يعني قتل منه واسقطوا على
الكبير من الطائرات كذلك فلم تكن لم تكن
حركه سلميه
درجه شكل وجودهم وانتقالهم من لا يريد ان
يكمل مع الجيش النظامي الروسي يشكلون عبء
على بيلاروسيا تستطيع ان تتحمله امنيا
وعسكريا
واستراتيجيا ايضا
ولو تذكرين منذ سنوات كانت هناك اتهامات
بانر حاولت ان تهدد نظام البيلاروسي في
فتره وكانت عمليه معقده يعني كان عمليه
استخباريه اوكرانيه بالاساس ولكن فهمت
بشكل خطا وتم القبض على عدد كبير منهم
يعني ابعادهم الى روسيا لتحقيق معهم
يوجد يوجد تهديد في هذا الاطار لانه وحده
القياده والسيطره على هذه المجموعات ربما
ابرزها وربما اكفاها ولكن ليست وحدها يعني
في عجاله ما مصير المناطق الموجوده فيها
في خاصه في مناطق افريقيا والاماكن التي
تسيطر عليها او تؤمنها على الاقل في عجاله
هذه المناطق هامه للغايه يعني هو لماذا هو
غاضب للغايه من قتله لانه قتلا هؤلاء
يمثلون له ثروه يعني هو هو حين يرسلهم الى
افريقيا حين يوصل
الممارسين الذين لهم خبرات كبيره الى
افريقيا هذه هذه
الانشطه تاتي لها تدل عليها اموالا كثيره
له هو شخصيا ولشركه كذلك لاستطيع ان
يستخدمها في مواجهه خصومه لحد ما ولكن حين
يقتل وحين يتعرضوا لبعض الاماكن الخطيره
مثل ما كان يحدث في في باخوه وفي غيرها
هذه خسائر لهذه شركه في النهايه هو هي
شركه ربحيه فبالتالي هو يريد ان يحافظ
عليهم بطريقه او باخرى وسحبهم من الاماكن
التي تمثل ربما خطوره وهذا في مقابل ايضا
يعرفون ذلك يعني يعرفون قواعد اللعبه
عناصرها في مقابل
ذهابهم للجيش الروسي مشكله مشكله ثانيه
الان انتصبت تحت رحمه
قد كنت قد يعني واجهتهم في فتره ما فسيكون
الامر ربما اكثر تعقيدا عمليه ضمهم
وعمليات الزامهم وربما يعني لا يامنون على
حياتهم لو حدث ذلك فهذه المشكله لم تنتهي
وربما سيكون لها حلقات اخرى للتحليلها
شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن دكتور عمر عاشور
استاذ ودراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا
على المشاركه معنا
نهايه الحص